heute brauchen wir keine Gabel denn
diese Pasta wurde von mir ermordet wir
machen Pasta al assassina hier ist alles
was wir jetzt brauchen unsere Pasta eine
Chilischote Knoblauch Tomatenmark und
passierte Tomaten als erstes Salzen wir
einen Topf mit ein bisschen kochendem
Wasser und lösen anschließend darin
Tomatenpüree auf und wir geben unseren
Knoblauch in die Pfanne mit unserer
Chili 20 30 Sekunden das ganze hier ein
bisschen anbraten jetzt wird Zeit das
ganze abzulöschen mit passierten Tomaten
als nächstes kommt unsere Pasta rein
einfach reinlegen drehe das Ganze einmal
schön durch so dass das sich wirklich
bedeckt mit unserem Zug was wir darin
haben dann nehmen sie die Feuchtigkeit
auf und lassen sich auch schon schön
biegen nach 5 Minuten ist es ein
bisschen angebrannt und es tut
vielleicht in der Seele weh aber es ist
notwendig jetzt lassen wir es auch von
der Gegenseite ungefähr 45 Minuten
anbrennen und dann geht's weiter und
jetzt gehen wir nach und nach von
unserer tomatenbrühe dazu und kochen so
unsere Nudeln aldente nach 10 Minuten
sind das ganze so aus und die Pasta ist
wunderbar all denkt also nehmen wir sie
und drapieren sie auf dem Teller
total lecker